welcome back to las vegas now guacan
margaritas are a match made in heaven if
you ask me and you can get that perfect
combo from el dorado cantina who are
sponsoring this segment and they have an
exciting new promotion happening that we
can't wait to talk about so here to fill
us in from el dorado cantina is ryan
clawson hi ryan hi thanks for having us
thanks for being here you brought go
walk and tequila
i'm happy
all right let's talk about this new
promotion it's called we wednesdays tell
us all about it so we wednesdays is a
way for everyone to come together and
kind of celebrate tequila and guacamole
we're offering uh nosotros tequila
partnered up with them nosotros means we
and when uh we in spanish we wednesday
kind of made sense and then we uh wanted
to feature our guacamole as well because
it is a house favorite
and uh we're doing that for half off so
nine dollar table side guacamole made
fresh wow you can't beat that and i have
had that table side guac before and i
know it's really good and it's really
fun because you can choose whatever
ingredients you want to put in it right
correct it is pretty tasty okay so
before we started the segment i grabbed
a chip because i just couldn't resist so
i'm going in for this walk because it
looks amazing and as i'm taking a bite
let's just talk a little bit about what
you guys are doing this week and why
wednesday is a big night wednesday is a
big night it's the night before
thanksgiving notoriously people like to
go out the night before thanksgiving
have some cocktails enjoy some food be
around friends that they maybe haven't
seen in a while so we wanted to
launch our promotion on that night as a
way for them to come experience that
have some delicious nosotros tequila and
let us make a ton of guacamole for them
to enjoy all night long i don't think i
heard a word you said because i was
distracted by how good the guac is
i know i'm just going to keep going over
here but no that sounds like so much fun
and the food is just delicious there
tell us a little bit about the menu some
of your other specialties if you're
coming in on any night of the week so el
dorado has uh
built up a following over time and we
feature you know outside of the
guacamole we have lobster tacos we have
filet tacos we do fajitas mushroom
lobster surf and turf
carnitas carne asada you name it the
flavors are fantastic
food is great and people really enjoy it
yeah every time i come i'm so full you
have to roll me out of there because
it's so good but i'm really excited
about this promotion do people need
reservations can they just show up
especially on the wee wednesdays i would
say make a reservation to be safe better
safe than sorry but if you don't feel
free to come in anyways and enjoy the
promotion and you have a few locations
around vegas right where can people find
you we have three of them now we have
one at tivoli village uh we have one in
the southwest off of buffalo and 215 and
then we have one near the las vegas
strip as well awesome well i have to ask
you what is your favorite ingredient in
guac do you go more on the cilantro side
the jalapenos what's your what's your
ghost i like the serranos i also like
the garlic okay oh i like the garlic
garlic yeah my co-host might not love it
if i'm eating a bunch of garlic and then
i have to go work with it
thank you so much this is really
exciting be sure to go to any of the el
dorado locations for we wednesdays you
can also call the number on your screen
there 702-333-1112
they also have a special offer five
dollar nosotros tequila shots and fifty
percent off table side guacamole can't
beat it rocky's